hello Israel's cabinet is set to vote on
the creation of an armed unit which the
national security minister itamar
bengavir says is critical in the fight
against what he calls terrorism the new
unit would report directly to the
security minister Ben gevir says the
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu agreed
to put the matter to a vote in exchange
for his support in delaying
controversial changes to the Judiciary
let's go live to West Jerusalem and
speak to Natasha name so do we expect
this resolution to pass when it's voted
on
well there is already a National Guard
in Israel but this proposal would
suggest a new and improved National
Guard if you will this is also not the
first time that a proposal has been put
forth regarding a beefed up National
Guard the last government allocated 277
million dollars to staff a guard about
1800 strong but that proposal never
gained any momentum so what's different
this time the difference is prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu made this
promise to his national security
minister as protests were roiling the
country last week it was at a standstill
this was over the judicial overhaul that
is being bandied about Netanyahu made
this promise to his national security
minister because his national security
minister it's Mar Ben gavir was
threatening to resign from the Coalition
which would have put the Coalition in
Jeopardy it has a slim majority this is
a pet project of Ben gevir Ben gavir is
a controversial far-right figure he has
been convicted of racist incitement and
supporting a terrorist group and this
National Guard as we're hearing now in
terms of this proposal would fall under
his purview right so Natasha would we
understand its mandate to be exactly
because critics are concerned that this
National Guard could be used to Target
Palestinians or to silence government
dissent
absolutely let's start with what Ben
gavier is saying he's calling this new
and improved National Guard good news
he's saying it would strengthen Security
in Israel and it would focus on
organized crime he says that would also
focus on Jewish groups involved in
organized crime but he says they would
operate in so-called mixed cities though
our those are cities here in Israel
where Palestinians and Israelis live
side by side the opposition is extremely
concerned in recent months during these
judicial overhaul protests Ben gevir has
called for taking a more heavy-handed
approach with protesters former prime
minister and opposition leader yair
lapid is saying that to fund this
National Guard Health Care
Transportation welfare and public
transportation would be cut to quote
finance a private Army of thugs the
opposition is worried about basically
Ben gevir overseeing what they are
worried would be tantamount to a private
militia former police commissioner is
also saying Ben gevir is a threat to
Israel and that this is a bad idea and
we know according to Israeli media that
last week or in the last week the
current Police Commissioner has written
a letter to Ben gevir saying that this
National Guard is absolutely unnecessary
has a high cost and would harm the
private security of citizens all right
Natasha thank you so much Natasha name
reporting from West Jerusalem